[Musique]
installé en france mais met au kenya
depuis 2005 nicolas risley puise son
inspiration dans ce pays à la nature
sauvage et aux traditions restée quasi
intacte
en fait ça a commencé avec les gens
parce que c'est le groupe n et que
j'admire et je trouve que il ya passé
john fait sur les groupes ethniques
montrer des gens intéressants notamment
les sombres où ce sont des cousins des
masaï mais ce que j'admire chez eux
c'est le désintérêt complet pour les
choses matérielles exactement l'opposé
de nous et il arrive de ce fait
conserver leur culture
une vie dans la savane au plus près des
animaux nicolas il retourne une fois par
an et passe du temps auprès des
différentes tribus
invité lors de cérémonies officielles
l'autodidacte tente de retranscrire au
mieux les tenues les coller et
l'attitude des habitants qui font
pousser les cheveux et j'adore la
manière dont ils mettent de l'ocré du de
la grèce dans les cheveux les cheveux
longs et c'est un tribut nilotique qui
fait qu'ils ont des très très faim et
j'adore donc l'ensemble les colliers le
trait les cheveux le regard
ce sont des gens qui ont l'habitude de
vivre dans la brousse donc ils ont une
vie très dure aussi une quarantaine de
toiles exposées comme un travail
d'anthropologue pour comprendre le
quotidien la culture de ces populations
un voyage au coeur de l'afrique
[Musique]